hi my name is Meredith Davis and I'm so
unbelievably excited and honored to be
speaking amongst all these amazing
empowering females I'm gonna take you on
my journey tonight my journey has been a
little unconventional
it starts from lugging around a suitcase
full of vibrators to becoming the
league's first employee and the one
thing that you'll hear me talk about a
lot tonight is my passions and my
mission and my mission has really been
the driving force in my career and has
really led me to where I am today which
is that I want to bring a voice to sex
dating and relationships and that
mission initially drove me to Indiana
University where I created my own major
in human sexuality I studied at the
world-renowned Kinsey Institute and I
did sex research for four years I
researched topics such as women's
arousal to what increases and decreases
pleasure and orgasms it was amazing
why wouldn't it be but while I was there
I realized that while I loved studying
sex I actually hated research and so I
am too much of an extra vote to be
sitting in a research lab so I thought
to myself okay it's second semester of
senior year and I need to figure out
what I'm gonna do in my life so I
thought about my mission and I started
to think about all the different career
paths that I could go into that would
align with that mission so I'm having
this conversation to myself and I'm
thinking all right here we go
OBGYN not taking that MCAT all right
stripper no I'm just I'm a really bad
dancer
but what about sex toys huh yeah sex
toys I could do that
so fast-forward to after graduation and
I landed a job at a high-end luxury sex
toy manufacturer based here in San
Francisco the company's mission was to
enhance relationships and bring pleasure
to the people awesome it was amazing and
it totally aligned with my own missions
and my own passions I was unstoppable
not even TSA could stop me when they let
me tell you do not travel with vibrators
every time I was at the airport I was
frisked because I was carrying a huge
oversized carry-on full of lithium-ion
batteries and vibrators unfortunately
soon after I started this new job the
company went through a major acquisition
and was purchased by a company that when
you walk into that dirty grimy sex toy
store and you see those phallic looking
products on the wall that's the company
that acquired mine and so all of a
sudden all the managers and execs those
who I was reporting to we're now
misogynistic uneducated and sitting on
billions of dollars from the porn
industry all of a sudden my mission of
bringing pleasure to the people was now
totally different and all of a sudden I
felt really unsafe in my work
environment
I was now being asked to unbutton my
shirt when I was at client meetings and
I was asked to sit on vendors laps all
of a sudden I was walking down a career
path that felt really scary and when I'm
about to say I actually have never said
in public I have a lot of co-workers and
a lot of friends in the crowd who don't
even know this part of my story because
the truth is I've been really ashamed
and embarrassed about it but I do think
it's unbelievably important in a shaped
Who I am today so I went to the CEO and
I really wanted to talk to him about how
uncomfortable I was not only was he
dismissive but he fired me so here I am
in San Francisco one of the most
expensive cities in the world I had no
money I had just been fired and the only
thing that I had was a huge oversized
bag full of dildos so I started to think
to myself well I've hit my rock-bottom
but sometimes hitting rock bottom is not
a bad place to start so I started
thinking again about my mission my
mission of bringing a voice to sex
dating and relationships and then I
realized I am in the headquarters of
every possible tech company you could
ever dream of all right so how do I
bridge the gap between sex and tech
dating apps
all right so now I just needed to
research so I started researching all
the different dating apps out there
tinder you know what man I know you have
higher standards than that we all should
have had higher standards than man but
what about the league hmm founded by
Amanda Bradford former Salesforce
Googler Stanford MBA aka
an alpha female badass creating a
platform where high achieving
individuals could seek out the other
part of their power couple
perfect all right so I needed an intro
I'd go on LinkedIn zero connections so
what is an unemployed gal to do try to
guess what her email is a Bradford at
the lead com Amanda at the lead com
Amanda dot Bradford autopear.com how
could I possibly figure out which one
was the right email I didn't
I simply emailed every single possible
combination I could think of hoping that
at one point one would go through
finally I got a response
that wasn't a bounce-back hi Meredith
thank you so much for your email
unfortunately we're not hiring right now
sincerely Amanda Bradford hi Amanda
thank you so so so much for your email
I'm attaching my resume below I would
really love the chance to talk to you I
believe that the league's mission very
much aligns with my own best Meredith
hi Meredith thanks again really love
your enthusiasm unfortunately we're not
hiring get back to us in six months to a
year hi Amanda I am now attaching every
single reference I could possibly think
of I would love to talk to you all right
Meredith why don't you come in for 15
minutes
well what can I say my persistence paid
off and I sure landed that one month
contract a higher position two years
later and I'm still here and I've seen a
lot in my two years and I've been a part
of growing the company and a part of
that has been a lot of hiring decisions
I've seen the company grow from 1 to 8
employees 8 back down to 3 3 to 20 and
the one thing that I will ask any
prospective hire is what is your passion
or what is your mission because I've
seen a lot of people come and go from
the league but the ones who are able to
handle the rockiness of a start-up are
those whose personal missions and values
align with ours you know I was talking
to Amanda the other day and we were
talking and she asked me what how would
you get off of a deserted island and
we're laughing and talking about it and
she looks at me and says you know what
Meredith you would build a boat but it
would not be a pretty boat in fact it
would have holes in it we may even sink
and you probably would forget to work to
build the oars but to work out of
start-up you don't need to necessarily
know how to build a boat but you got to
believe that you got to get yourself off
that Island and so that's something that
we look at when we're hiring is people
who are scrappy people who will ask you
and
people who will do anything that needs
to be done in order to promote the
leaves missions and passions and you
know sometimes it's not always pretty
and the water is not always rocky or not
always clear
some days I'm having to run QA tests and
some days are not fun and I'm having to
pull data other days I am trying to hire
a tarot card reader or a sword swallower
for a party that we're hosting but I am
constantly reminding myself that I am on
the greater path of promoting the
league's missions and creating power
couples and enhancing relationships and
you know doing this for other people and
helping others and growing their
relationships has definitely affected my
personal relationships I can't deny that
my dating life has taken a hit I mean
thank God I have all those dildos still
but I'm constantly reminding myself that
my personal missions and bringing a
voice to sex dating and relationships
align with the leaves and so if you're
to take away anything tonight take away
the fact that you should not that you
should follow your passions and that
sometimes hitting rock bottom is not
always a bad place to be and don't play
it safe and don't play it conventional
and if you play play with a clear
purpose and mission so write down what
you're passionate about and follow that
mission of yours and don't ever lose
sight of it because that mission is
going to be the most important thing in
order for you to follow your careers
thank you
[Applause]